so every year i look at and i'll take an
inventory of myself and our organization
different departments different
companies that we run to see what
weaknesses we have what blind spots we
have and one area
that kept coming up in 2021 was us
having a hard time sitting down having
difficult conversations so either people
were having difficult conversations or
if they were they did not know how to do
it and they were offending others and it
was challenging so so listen we need to
invest some money into it so i brought
an organization that i've done business
with and i've been to their conferences
before multiple times they're based out
of utah i brought them in and i invested
thirty thousand dollars and i put myself
i was in the course for two days this
was just a month ago by the way and i
sat through every single thing training
that they did it was eight hours a day
and it was 20 employees that we did in
fort lauderdale it was the media company
and then i did 20 of our executives and
c-suites and directors in dallas and it
cost us 60 thousand dollars within four
days two was two days was in uh florida
two days was in dallas but what happened
after this meeting the level of autonomy
amongst the leaders went to a whole
different level so what's the point here
am i selling you a conflict resolution
course not at all here's what i'm
telling you i want you to be thinking
about what areas of weakness does your
team currently have with the current
conditions that we're in people are
afraid
they're nervous they have anxiety they
don't know what to do next these are the
times that you invest into your guys to
recreate themselves including yourself
with new strategies and hacks and that's
why at the vault conference
based on what a lot of ceos and
executives were asking about is pat can
we do a discount if i'm willing to bring
three five 10 20 different people and we
said yes there's a 20 discount for those
of you that want to bring your teammates
and invest into your organization click
on the link above or below if you buy
three or more tickets you get a 20
discount to attend the vault conference
in miami i'll see you guys there take
care bye bye bye bye bye